Останні хвилини перед виходом з українського порту в Одесі.
Американський есмінець Carney є одним з найкраще оснащених
в 6-ому флоті США і прийшов в Чорне море
для участі у міжнародних навчаннях Сібриз 2019.
Есмінець прямує до нейтральних вод, щоб власне розпочати маневри.
Карін Лі керує системою запуску ракет.
Ось вона - головна зброя есмінця.
Це система вертикального запуску ракет.
Залежно від того, що в ній завантажено,
може бути використана зброя різної дальності і для різних цілей.
Це може бути і наступальна зброя, і  "томагавки".
Схоже, що присутність американського есмінцю з «томагавками» -
ракетами великої дальності - на борту непокоїть російських військових.
В небі раптом з’являється СУ-24,
оснащений двома протикорабельними ракетами.
За есмінцем постійно стежать ще й кораблі РФ,
які прийшли з Криму в район навчань.
Капітан американського есмінцю Тайсон Янг показує -
в акваторії маневрів, а це північно-західна частина Чорного моря,
стоять ще два або три російські кораблі.
Російську присутність він коментує без зайвих емоцій.
Я б не назвав цю ситуацію якоюсь зустріччю з росіянами.
Жоден з кораблів не підходить занадто близько.
Жодна зі сторін не ставить під загрозу інші судна.
Що стосується літака – російський  СУ-24
перебуває в міжнародному повітряному просторі,
неподалік від місця знаходження учасників Сі Бриз.
жодна його дія поки не перевищувала межі дозволеного.
Маневрування було зроблено професійно.
Ззовні здається, що поява росіян
ніяк не впливає на перебіг міжнародних навчань.
Хоча буквально перед початком маневрів
Росія перекрила одну з ділянок  Чорного моря,
тому українським військовим довелося змінити тренувальну локацію.
опри це, американці спільно з українським фрегатом «Гетьман Сагайдачний»
і одним з румунських корветів відпрацьовують маневрування далі.
Завдання - відпрацювати патрулювання та оперативну сумісність з союзниками.
Звучить наче просто, але кораблям це не одразу вдається.
Крім того, тренування відбуваються і на борту.
Американці готують зброю для наступної операції.
Раптом лунає повідомлення….
"Ви наближаєтесь до суднА уряду США. Негайно змініть курс!"
Військово-морські навчання на есмінці враз переходять в активну фазу.
Треба зібрати повний комплект засобів захисту, оборони та нападу.
Команда з 9-тьох американських моряків готується до висадки.
Ми перебуваємо в нейтральних водах.
Праворуч десь Крим, ліворуч - Одеса.
Американські військові мають, за легендою навчань,
висадитися на підозріле судно та перевірити його.
Це болгарський корабель Бодрий.
Американці кілька разів поспіль відпрацьовують безпечну висадку.
Один з командорів есмінця «Карні» - Даглас Рено
має українське коріння,
його родина дотримується і українських свят, і традицій.
Даглас вперше відвідує Україну.
Він в курсі про неспокійну ситуацію в Чорному і Азовському морях,
про напружені відносини між Україною і Росією.
Його відповідь на відверте запитання:
чи готовий він стати на захист України, така:
Я виконую всі вказівки командування.
Я не розробляю політичні рішення , я їх виконую.
США виступає щодо підтримки регіональної стабільності
та вільному руху кораблів усіх країн по морських шляхах.
Даглас додає, що приємно вражений рівнем підготовки українських колег
і радий нагоді  спільно відпрацювати потенційні військові завдання.
На користь від співпраці з країнами НАТО розраховує
і командувач Військово-морських сил Збройних сил України адмірал Воронченко.
Стратегічно вони повинні продемонструвати єдність
НАТО з Україною
стосовно бажання НАТО
підтримувати паритет сил в чорноморському регіоні.
За останній рік кораблі НАТО
достатньо збільшили присутність в Чорному морі.
І  зараз, як ви бачити, кораблі і  постійно діюча група
зайшли в Чорне морі, і  розвідувальний корабель Франції зайшов.
За перші три дні навчань росіяни фактично не залишали район маневрів.
Ось знімальна група DW спостерігає
ще і наближення гвинтокрила класу Ка.
Ще до початку військово-морських навчань Сі Бриз
російське керівництво традиційно обурилося появі американських кораблів
в Чорному морі та назвало самІ маневри
спробою тиску та демонстрацією сили з боку США.
Багатьом морякам на есмінці це не дуже цікаво.
Кажуть, в них багато роботи.
А ще треба встигати розважатися. Ось, приміром, так:
Ще у вільний час можна зробити собі зачіску
або поспівати ….про щось рІдне-американське.
Поки йдуть навчання, життя на Carney не припиняється.
Carney можна порівняти з великою багатоповерхівкою.
Кілька поверхів під водою і кілька над водою.
В це важко повірити, але тут мешкають майже триста 300 людей.
Здебільшого чоловіки. Жінок  тут, як і на усіх кораблях ВМС США -
15-20% команди. Екіпаж в морі
щонайменше кілька місяців поспіль.
Мінімальний контракт - річнИй. Знімальній групі Deutsche Welle
дозволили оглянути різні приміщення.
Хоча і коридори тут вузькІ, і кімнати маленькі.
Ось, тут сплять жінки, наче в тримісному купе у потягах.
Усі меблі – мініатюрні.
Все ж тут можна жити. І навіть в магазин піти.
Команда обожнює енергетики!
У ВМС США діє своя валюта. Морські долари.
Гроші кладуть ось на таку картку:
один неморський долар дорівнює одному морському.
Свій морський гаманець моряки поповнюють із зарплати.
З неї ж вираховують гроші за харчування.
В їдальні завжди можна отримати щонайменше три страви.
Корабельні коки знаються на різних кухнях світу.
Все дуже ситне. Моряків постійно попереджають –
вага набирається стрімко, тож треба постійно рухатися.
Ось як Роб: вдень відповідає за роботу машинного відділення,
а ввечері - постійний гість у спортзалі.
На кораблі два фітнес-центри і можна тренуватися цілодобово.
Тим часом на поверхні моря, на сусідньому болгарському кораблі
саме розгортається наступна фаза навчань.
Приблизно через дві години команда повертається.
Ми зробили це дуже добре. …. Я думаю, що ніхто не зробив помилок.
Через два дні, по завершенні цієї фази навчань есмінець «Карні»
повертається в порт Одеси.
На честь Дня незалежності США лунає американський гімн.
В міжнародних навчаннях Сібриз-2019
беруть участь 19 країн,
32 кораблі, 24 літаки   та понад три тисячі військових.
Навчання проводять не лише на морі, а і на суші, навіть в дельті Дунаю.
Росія назвала це провокацією та агресією.
Україна – посиленням співпраці з союзниками.